the choice to bear a child is one of the
most personal choices a person can make
that doesn't mean the government has no
interest in the decision
the fact is it's an important decision
important to the individual and
important to society
so it's not surprising that mandatory
sterilization bans on the distribution
or use of contraceptives and
restrictions on abortion have been in
some cases still are part of our history
of course some forms of regulation in
this area are foreign to our traditions
never for example is the united states
seen anything like the one child policy
adopted in china in 1979
in this lecture we will consider each of
the possible choices relating to
childbirth the choice to try to become
pregnant or father a child the choice
not to become pregnant and the choice to
terminate a pregnancy
each of these personal choices personal
liberties that they came to be seen has
been the subject of the supreme court's
attention during the past century
we began in 1924 with the story of kerry
buck
kerry was an 18 year old patient at the
virginia state colony for epileptics and
the feeble-minded she probably never
belonged there but that's where she was
according to the superintendent of the
institution carrie had a mental age of
nine
she had attended school only through
sixth grade harry lived with the foster
family her birth mother was said to have
the mental age of eight they liked to
attach mental ages to people back then
shortly before entering the institution
kerry had given birth to an illegitimate
child a daughter
this it seems was the reason her foster
family sent her there
but carrie could scarcely be blamed for
the pregnancy she had been raped by a
nephew of her foster mother her
commitment later that year was most
likely an effort by the family to save
its reputation
well in that year of 1924 virginia had
adopted a statute that authorized the
sterilization of the intellectually
disabled
the law had been pushed by proponents of
eugenics supporters of the law believed
doctors were refusing to sterilize women
who deserve sterilization because they
were afraid of prosecution
the new law was meant to remove that
threat
dr albert priddy saw kerry buck as a
genetic threat to society he called her
incorrigible and said that without
sterilization there was a high risk she
would produce offspring
so dr priddy filed the necessary
paperwork to sterilize kerry
his request was approved by the
institution's board of directors
but kerry's legal guardian challenged
the sterilization order in court and
that challenge eventually made its way
to the united states supreme court
carrie through her guardian argued that
involuntary sterilization would violate
her right to due process and equal
protection under the 14th amendment
the right to procreate they argued was a
fundamental right and it was a right
that could not be denied by state law
but the supreme court by an eight-to-one
boat disagreed
the court accepted that kerry was quote
feeble-minded and promiscuous and that
it was in the best interest of the state
to sterilizer
writing for the court justice oliver
wendell holmes wrote that the state's
interest in preserving the public
welfare outweighed kerry's interest in
bodily integrity and personal choice
in the words of justice holmes we have
seen more than once that the public
welfare may call upon the best citizens
for their lives it would be strange if
it could not call upon those who already
sapped the strength of the state for
these lesser sacrifices to prevent our
being swamped with incompetence
he added
three generations of imbeciles are
enough
memorable but not one of holmes's finest
moments
carrie buck received a tubal location
she was later released from the
institution
kerry by the way became an avid reader
and was so until her death in 1983
and her daughter who had been
erroneously labeled feeble-minded after
a quick examination by a eugenics field
worker turned out to be a solid student
even being listed on her school's honor
roll
the course ruling in buck versus bell
encouraged dozens of additional states
to enact compulsory sterilization laws
virginia's sterilization law remained on
the books until its repeal in 1974.
buck versus bell was not the only
supreme court case to consider mandatory
sterilization
in 1942 the court considered an oklahoma
law that required the sterilization of
all three-time felons
a sort of three-strike senior snip law
an oklahoman by the name of jack skinner
made the mistake of stealing some
chickens
it was skinner's third felony and as
part of his punishment he was ordered to
undergo a vasectomy
skinner sued and in the case of skinner
versus oklahoma the supreme court sided
with him
different justices gave different
reasons for reaching their conclusion
the majority felt the law violated
skinner's right to equal protection of
the laws
the court said the choice to procreate
was so fundamental that the state needed
a strong reason to take it away a reason
that oklahoma didn't have
chief justice stone believed the law
violated skinner's due process rights he
was entitled to a hearing on the
question of whether his criminal
tendencies were of an inheritable type
and he never got such a hearing
and for justice jackson oklahoma's law
violated both equal protection and due
process justice jackson wrote there are
limits to the extent to which a
legislatively represented majority may
conduct biological experiments at the
expense of the dignity of a minority
even those who have been guilty of what
the majority defined as crimes
after skinner and after the public
learned about the eugenics program of
nazi germany sterilization rates dropped
dramatically
by the 1960s restrictions on the use of
contraceptives became more of an issue
than sterilization laws
two cases challenging restrictions on
the distribution of contraceptives
reached the court and were decided on
their merits
the first was a case of griswold versus
connecticut
in griswold the court found a state law
banning the distribution of
contraceptives to be an unconstitutional
burden on the right of marital privacy
which justice william o douglas found to
be implicit in the bill of rights
in a wonderfully metaphysical opinion
justice douglas talked about the various
protections of the bill of rights having
penumbras and emanations that
effectively extended their reach
granted nothing in the constitution
specifically says states can't regulate
the use of contraceptives but no matter
douglas argued that the emanations of
the first third fourth and fifth
amendments made obvious the framers
intention to create a zone of privacy
that the state could not invade
and threatening married couples with
jail time for using contraceptives was
just such an unconstitutional invasion
in a concurring opinion the usually
conservative justice john harlan
conjured up the image of police officers
snooping around in what he called the
sacred precincts of the marital bedroom
for telltale evidence of contraceptive
use
in another interesting concurring
opinion justice arthur goldberg saw the
connecticut law as a violation of the
ninth amendment which reads
the enumeration in the constitution of
certain rights shall not be construed to
deny or disparage others retained by the
people
goldberg quoted james madison's reasons
for drafting the ninth amendment
madison said
it's been objected also against a bill
of rights that by enumerating particular
exceptions to the grant of power it
would disparage those rights which were
not placed in that enumeration and it
might follow by implication that those
rights which were not singled out were
intended to be assigned into the hands
of the general government and were
consequently
insecure
this is one of the most plausible
arguments i have ever heard urged
against the admission of a bill of
rights into the system but i conceive
that it may be guarded against i have
attempted it as gentlemen may see by
turning to the last clause of the ninth
amendment
over the years many judges and legal
scholars from the original school have
criticized the interpretation of
griswold versus connecticut
famously judge robert bork's criticism
of the decision and its recognition of a
privacy right proved to be his undoing
in the hearings on his nomination to the
supreme court
judge bork compared the ninth amendment
to an ink blot on the constitution
we can't figure out what madison and the
framers meant
so let's not even try
griswold recognized a right of marital
privacy a right that included the right
to possess and use contraceptives
but it left open the question of whether
the constitution protected the right of
unmarried persons to use contraceptives
some states argue that allowing single
people to use contraceptives would lead
to promiscuity
a former medical student named william
baird challenged the legal validity of
that argument
in 1965 in new york baird engaged in an
unusual form of civil disobedience he
handed out contraceptives to anyone who
wanted them
it was illegal at the time to distribute
contraceptives without a license
baird was arrested and prosecuted and as
a result of his protest he lost his job
with a pharmaceutical company
but baird remained undeterred two years
later in massachusetts he was at it
again
massachusetts law allowed only married
persons to obtain contraceptives and
then only with a doctor's prescription
so baird showed up for a speaking
engagement at boston university with
several boxes of contraceptives
about 2 000 people mostly students were
intended in attendance and during his
speech baird asked volunteers to come
forward to distribute contraceptives
contraceptive foam and condense to
anyone in the audience who wanted them
then he asked the police in the hall to
come and arrest him
his goal of course was to bring a test
case challenging the massachusetts ban
on the distribution of contraceptives to
unmarried persons
he was arrested and booked entered a cle
a plea of not guilty and he was released
on bail
well
things did not work out well in the
state courts for baird
he was convicted in a non-jury trial and
then the massachusetts supreme court on
a 4-3 vote
upheld his conviction and his
three-month prison zones
barrett spent 35 days in the charles
street jail before the u.s supreme court
agreed to hear his appeal
the case known as eisenstadt versus
baird was decided in 1972.
the majority voted to overturn baird's
conviction
writing for the court just as william
brennan inserted language that would
prove useful in another majority opinion
decided soon thereafter
roe versus wade
brennan wrote if the right of privacy
means anything it is the right of the
individual married or single to be free
from unwarranted governmental intrusion
into matters so fundamentally affecting
a person is a decision whether to bear
or beget a child
and so we come to one of the most
controversial decisions ever made by the
u.s supreme court
a case is centered on the claim of a
young woman named norma mccorvey
now norma mccorvey could do one thing
well
shoot pool
in 1969 at age 21 she liked to play at a
mostly lesbian bar called the white
carriage in dallas
mccorvey organized tournaments
held the bets and divided up the prize
money
some straight men came and liked to go
to the carriage to shoot pool with the
women
one saturday night a man who mccorvey
thought to be about 50 years old asked
her to be her pool partner
norma later gave the man the name carl
but that wasn't his real name
carl was a good pool player he and
mccorvey won their matches that evening
and took home 100 bucks
the two began to play together regularly
at bars around dallas
and eventually mccorvey started sleeping
with carl
they'd rank together drop some acid
together
mccarvey wrote later of their
relationship we were rebels outlaws
together
but she knew it wouldn't last
it ended when carl dropped norma off at
her mother's trailer in louisiana
he waved and headed out on his way to
las vegas
norma would never see carl again
in louisiana mccorvey landed a job
running an animal freak show at a
traveling carnival she stood outside a
tent each evening pitching the show and
selling tickets
with 30 dollars to her name sleeping in
a carnival trunk
norma realized she was pregnant
she described herself as numb past
caring
a pregnant redneck hippie carnie
she took a bus back to dallas
norma said she couldn't bear to think of
carrying a baby
it was simply a thing growing inside me
getting bigger every day
she didn't want the child to be born
with me as its mother
a friend told mccorvey that a doctor
might be able to terminate her pregnancy
interestingly the word abortion was
completely foreign to her
she visited her
obstetrician
the same doctor who had delivered two
previous babies said she'd given up for
adoption
the doctor told her that he did not
perform abortions
in fact if you learned of anyone doing
them he'd be obligated to report them
he told her you really should have
thought of this before you got pregnant
before she left the doctor gave her the
phone number of a lawyer
norma mccorvey met with the lawyer in
his office at first he tried to talk
mccorvey into putting the baby up for
adoption
but corby said she'd prefer to get an
abortion
wherever she can find it
you might well get yourself killed you
warned then he said
i know a couple of young lawyers who are
looking for a pregnant woman who wants
an abortion
a woman just like you
they need a plaintiff in a lawsuit to
help them overturn the texas law against
abortions
in february 1970 in an italian
restaurant in dallas mccorvey met the
two lawyers who would take her case to
the supreme court of the united states
linda coffey and sarah weddington
weddington asked mccorvey if she really
wanted an abortion and why
corby said that pregnancy was making her
life miserable
it made it almost impossible for her to
find work
mostly though she complained she didn't
want this thing as she called it growing
inside her body
weddington told mccorvey stories of
shady doctors and botched back alley
abortions then she asked norma if she
agreed that all women should have access
to safe and legal abortions
she said sure of course
and then she began to cry
weddington and coffey filed a lawsuit
against the state of texas and norman
mccarvey became the lead plaintiff jane
rowe in the case that would eventually
become known as roe vs wade
but mccorvey was already about six
months pregnant
and getting a case to the supreme court
takes years not weeks
mccarvey spent the next couple of months
smoking dope drinking wine and living
with what she called a group of hippies
she tried not to think about her
pregnancy
she wasn't even present when her lawsuit
was heard by a panel of three federal
district court judges
the panel handed her a victory of sorts
striking down the texas law that
prohibited abortions except when
necessary to save the life of the mother
but that victory proved hollow when
district attorney henry wade appealed
the case and the order was stayed
pending the appeal
wade announced that he would prosecute
any doctor who performed an abortion
mccorvey then realized what should have
been obvious to a first-year law student
this case was not really about her
she felt used and she took the news hard
norma's water broke in the middle of the
night her baby was delivered within
minutes after arrival in the emergency
room and was put up for adoption
norma felt depressed and spent the next
several days drinking heavily
she swallowed dozens of pills to end it
all
she hallucinated lost consciousness but
woke up a day later still alive
the birth of jane rose that is norma
mccorvey's baby did not moot the case
the suit was brought as a class action
on behalf not only of mccorvey but also
unnamed pregnant women in the state of
texas who might desire an abortion
in march 1971 the supreme court
announced that it would hear the case of
roe versus wade
sarah weddington moved from austin to
new york city to work with women's
rights lawyers on preparation for the
argument
the court had actually taken the road
case not to decide the abortion issue
but rather to consider another question
raised by the case specifically whether
women and doctors who wish to challenge
state abortion laws could go first to
federal court rather than going through
all the possible appeals at the state
level first
in oral arguments sarah weddington
seemed to be surprised by the court's
focus on the jurisdictional issue
and on the substantive question of what
provision in the constitution supported
a right to abortion she seemed unsure of
where to point
after weddington rattled off a long list
of potential economic and psychological
harms associated with giving birth to an
unwanted child
just as potter steward tried to steer to
the constitutional text
he noted rather paternalistically
sometimes in the court we would like to
sometimes but we cannot be here involved
simply with matters of policy as you
know
weddington took the hint
we originally brought the suit alleging
the due process clause the equal
protection clause the ninth amendment
and a variety of others she said
justice stewart interrupted and asked
sarcastically and anything else that
might be applicable
yes yeah weddington answered as many in
the courtroom laughed
justice byron white asked whether
weddington was claiming that women had a
right to choose an abortion even late in
their pregnancies
well do you or don't you say that the
constitutional right you insist on
reaches up to the time of birth
weddington gave the most radical answer
possible
suggesting that the constitution gives
protection to people only after birth
until then a woman's right to choose
should be in force
birth is not the point at which the
court could ever draw the line
an abortion at eight and a half months
just seems too close to infanticide
but the court seemed equally
uncomfortable with the line proposed by
assistant attorney general of texas jay
floyd
asked when a fetus has full
constitutional protection floyd answered
at any time there is life from the
moment of impregnation
when floyd pointed to a section of the
state's brief showing the development of
the fetus beginning at seven days after
conception justice thurgood marshall
jumped in
well what about six days we don't know
floyd replied but the statute goes all
the way back to one hour marshall
pointed out
there are unanswerable questions in this
field floyd conceded
only seven justices gathered in the
supreme court conference room to decide
the row case two vacancies remained
unfilled
the next year justice rehnquist and
powell would join the court
to the surprise of the three most
liberal justices on the court the
jurisdictional issue was suddenly off
the table
swing justice potter stewart joined them
in another case decided the same day
allowing a bookstore owner to challenge
a state obscenity law in federal court
before exhausting state court remedies
the same principles would have to apply
in row
so the court would reach the merits
after all and on the merits there were
three solid votes just write down the
texas law
justices marshall brennan and douglas
two justices favored a narrow ruling
against portions of the law
justices blackmon and steward seemed
ready to base their decision on the
right of doctors not women a right to
exercise their professional judgment
free of state interference
chief justice warren berger assigned the
task of writing the court's opinion to
justice harry blackman
at this early point in his supreme court
career had a mostly conservative voting
record
but before joining the court he had
served as the general counsel to the
mayo clinic
he had a great respect for doctors and
saw the doctor-patient relationship as
something close to sacred
blackman loved working with the surgical
staff he called the 10 years at mayo the
best of his life
one of his jobs had been to advise the
staff on the legality of abortions the
hospital performed
and many of those he approved would not
have been legal in the state of texas
blackman poured hundreds of hours into
crafting an opinion he worked through
the fall and winter doing research in
the court's library he read both medical
and legal texts taking careful notes
he discovered that abortion had
generally been legal in the united
states until the 19th century the bans
were put in place to protect pregnant
women against what was at the time a
dangerous operation
but now abortions were safer than
childbirth to blackman that fact argued
strongly in favor of legalizing early
abortions
in may of 1972 blackman finally
circulated his draft opinion to the
other justices but the opinion was short
on analysis
it indicated that women had a right to
privacy that included a right to choose
an abortion but it didn't say where in
the constitution that right came from
the opinion simply concluded the texas
law was too vague to be constitutional
black men seemed to suggest that
abortion should be legal until the time
the fetus became viable outside of the
womb
but it didn't directly say that laws
against early abortions were always
unconstitutional
hardly the sort of guidance the medical
profession would like
blackman became convinced of his opinion
shortcomings especially after reading
dissent from justice white
he withdrew his opinion
meanwhile justices renquist and powell
took their seats on the court
lewis powell's father-in-law had been a
prominent obstetrician
confident that he could get powell's
vote blackman urged roe to be re-argued
the next term
and over the strong objection of justice
william o douglas the court voted to do
just that
blackman spent much of the summer of
1972 in minnesota researching abortion
at the mayo clinics library he reworked
his draft to make the right of privacy
explicit
women had a constitutional right to
choose whether or not to bear a child
here the contraceptive cases present
provided the precedent
the court said in eisenstadt women
should be able to choose whether or not
to bear a child
the right to an abortion he wrote was
not absolute the state had a compelling
interest in regulating abortions to
protect women's health especially after
three months when the risks increase
and at some point the interest of the
state in protecting the life of the
fetus overrode the privacy interests
for lack of a better place to draw the
line blackman said that the point came
about six months into the pregnancy
so rose trimester framework emerged
blackman also declared that a fetus was
not a person in the constitutional sense
the right to liberty under the
constitution attaches only after birth
of course if fetuses were persons within
the meaning of the constitution
abortions would be a gross violation of
rights
the case was re-argued in october but it
was nearly a pointless exercise
the votes were in six justices joined
blackman in a 7-2 decision issued on
january 22 1973.
in his dissent justice white offered
strong words
i find nothing in the language or
history of the constitution to support
the court's judgment as an exercise of
raw judicial power the court perhaps has
authority to do what it does today but
in my view its judgment is an
improvement and extravagant exercise of
the power of judicial review
the public reaction was even stronger
cardinal terence cook asked how many
millions of children will never live to
see the light of day because of this
shocking decision of the supreme court
today
cardinal john kroll said it was hard to
think of any decision in the 200 years
of our history that had more disastrous
implications for his stability as a
civilized society
the state of texas filed a petition for
re-hearing comparing the decision to
dred scott
norma mccorvey found out she won her
case at the kitchen table in a house she
shared with connie gonzalez the woman
who became her lover and partner
she read the story on the front page of
the dallas times herald
norma had never told connie about her
role in the abortion case
she asked connie
how would you like to meet jane rowe
but mccorvey's views would change she
converted to catholicism by 1997 she was
ardently pro-life and even participated
in anti-abortion protests
norma died in 2017 at the age of 69.
roe vs wade was more the beginning of
the abortion debate than the end of it
the core liberty protected by roe
remains at least at the time of this
lecture
but the court has abandoned roe's
trimester framework it now upholds state
regulations which do not quote
pose an undue burden on that right
roe versus wade has changed americans
politics in ways too numerous to mention
it's become a litmus test for candidates
in both major parties
it is a highly emotional and complicated
issue
abortions are at least morally dubious
and one can ask whether societal
acceptance of morally dubious actions
makes it more likely we will come to
accept morally wrong decisions
infanticide perhaps
on the other hand many americans might
understand that pregnancies and
childbirth seriously affect the lives of
women
and they might believe that when a woman
and her doctor decide abortion is the
better option little is to be gained by
locking the doctor in jail
ultimately as they say that's where the
rubber meets the road
anyone who says the abortion question is
an easy one isn't thinking very hard
about the issue
it's tough
damn tough
you